thank you
good morning everyone so we are going to
talk about some things pandas but let's
briefly introduce ourselves
I'm yours I'm from Belgium I'm yeah
involved in several open source projects
I'm a core developer of pandas if you're
working with geospatial data at Giovanna
Shipley I'm very happy to chat about
that as well and currently I'm working
on Apache arrow on mostly on the python
bindings at the Voltron data where we're
building our own native data analytics
good morning for me as well I'm Patrick
I'm also a panda's call contributor I'm
currently working at Coyle mostly on
task
I'm calling to ask scale your python
code and ask mostly works on all the pi
data libraries while I'm coil provides
distributed infrastructure in the cloud
s and I will talk about the pandas 2.0
release
the actual release happened two weeks
ago on April 3rd
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
we will go briefly over a couple of
features that are already turned on by
default like
pandas 2.0 supports arbitrarily
numerical nump ID types and indexes
which wasn't possible before then we
introduced non-nanosecond daytime
resolutions
and a consistent data and parsing
mechanism
and afterwards yours will talk about
copy and write which is still optional
and I will talk about aerobact data
frames which are also optional right now
um
up until pandas 2.0 it wasn't possible
to create timestamps that were not
represented in nanosecond resolutions
nanosecond resolution means that every
timestamp is represented in nanoseconds
starting from the 1st of January 1970.
this means that because of N64 range
that it was not possible to represent
timestamps outside of the 1677 and 2262.
if you tried this you always got an out
of bounds daytime error looks like this
in pandas 2.0 we were able to lift this
restriction and we support now several
different resolutions
um
the lowest one is second and then we
have milliseconds microseconds at
nanoseconds with seconds you're able to
represent timestamps over a range of 290
billion years which should be plenty I
hope
um
let's look a bit into how you can enable
the new resolution
it's still new and that's a lot of work
so it's not supported everywhere yet
date range at least for me is a popular
function to instantiate like a Time
series for testing purposes but it does
not support the non-nanosecond
resolution yet
so you'll always get an index that is
still represented in nanoseconds
you can easily convert between different
resolutions with s unit that's the new
method that was added for pandas 2.0
so as unit with seconds this simply
converts your daytime index to a second
resolution
there's also an option to do this with
S-Type but personally I would recommend
to use S unit if you just want to switch
between different resolutions simply
because um as type was built for
something more and actually casting your
data types and not only converting
different resolutions
one of the breaking changes with pandas
2.0 is
previously if a user provided a numpy
array with any date time 60 40 type the
resolution was always cast to
nanoseconds because pandas didn't
support anything else
starting with pandas 2.0 the resolution
is preserved as long as it's possible
meaning if it's seconds microseconds
milliseconds or nanoseconds we keep it
and otherwise we cast to the closest
resolution available so something like
day would be cast to seconds and not
nanoseconds anymore
so you have to be careful if you don't
want that um then you will have to
adjust your code
some caveats about nanosecond support in
pandas
it's new it was developed between 1.5
and 2.0
so it's only like six months of
development work
and it's not supported yet in every part
of the API the assumption that at
timestamp is represented in nanoseconds
was deeply baked into the pandas
internals you can find this everywhere
if you're dealing with timestamps so it
will take a bit of time to get rid of
that everywhere
um so please if you run into something
that's not working as expected then just
file a pack report and we'll take care
of it as soon as possible
this is something I ran into like after
the 2.0 release came out
if you are comparing with smaller or
smaller input and equal then
um to
um serious with different time stamps
with different nanosec resolutions
um
this is still relatively slow we are now
doing our best effort to convert to a
consistent resolution but this is not
always possible if the accuracy is
different for example
um so yeah we would like you to try it
out and give us feedback on this
this brings us to a related item an
enhancement proposal for pandas that was
implemented for 2.0
um try to streamline the daytime parsing
mechanism before 2.0 if you had um
scalars like we see here 1201 2013 or
one two thousand
it would try to parse them with month
first that means it would infer that the
12 in the beginning is the month
followed by the day and then the year
obviously so you get the first of
December
the second scalar doesn't fit this
notation though because 13 is not a
valid month so it would switch in the
middle
um to infer day as the first element
and use o1 as the month so you would get
the first of December and the 13th of
January which is like not very nice
um in pandas 2.0 if no format is
provided
then it will always use the the format
it's inferred from the first scalar and
use this for every other scalar that's
in your provided list if this doesn't
work at some point then we throw an
error instead of like mixing formats up
in the middle
you can read more about the pdip in
General on our website
okay
um I will now
um go a bit into more detail
um on the first experimental feature
that is included in panace 2.0 about
copy view semantics behavior in pandas
or how we can get rid of the the setting
with copy warning
I assume that if you use pandas you
probably have seen this warning have run
into it you can also find a lot of
lengthy blog posts online explaining
where it comes from how you can solve it
Etc so I will try to do a very brief
attempt to explain the context here and
that's so the example I'm creating a
small data frame
I'm filtering the data frame using a
Boolean filtering masking operation I
get a subset and then I modify another
column of this subset this triggers the
running and the the reason that this
warning exists here is that
it's a question if I modify this subsets
do I intend to modify the original data
frame DF as well and so to know the
answer to that question you need to know
something about copies and Views
very briefly
if you have a data frame uh df1 and you
have a second data frame which is a view
that means that they under the hood
share the actual share the same data
while if you have a copy the F2 is a
copy then it has its own data in memory
and so if you then modify such a view if
I modify the F2 since they actually
share the same data and memory if you
modify it in place of course you also
modify the original data frame well in
the case of a copy that's not the case
but as a consequence this
um yeah as
introduces some confusing behavior
um you need to where you you need to be
aware of this copy versus view you also
need to be aware of how numpy works with
that for example slicing gives a few
selecting with the mask or with the list
gives a copy and in addition pandas also
like yeah there's more than non-pays so
the rules get a bit more complicated
um
and so the so for example if if we
um so the or the reason that the running
was originally introduced is
for a case like this where this copy
those the rules around copy and Views
gives a confusing Behavior so and that's
what is called change assignment so I'm
trying to modify a data frame but I'm
doing that
using a chain of operations so I have a
small data frame and I want to modify
the values of the column C based on some
row selection
we can do that in those two ways one
works and the other doesn't work
if you rewrite the second case what
you're actually doing because it's
changed in two steps you can write that
also on two lines so first we are
selecting the rows that gives us a
temporary object and this temporary
object we then modify that column
but in this case it's a Boolean mask and
that gives a copy so we're actually
modifying the column of a copy so that
yeah that doesn't work to update the
original data frame and so that's the
reason that the setting with copy
running was introduced to warn you about
this
but of course also like if I take the
previous example where I created this
subset explicitly and not just as a
temporary object implicitly
um I now also get this warning because
pandas doesn't know if you are modifying
subset that you want to modify DF or not
and so in general
what do people say how how can you solve
this warning that's
either
if your intent was to update the
original data frame you can use you
should avoid this change assignment you
can do that in one go using Dot Lock
providing your row selection column
section in one go so that's one option
or you could also use a method like
assign to update values
on the other hand if you're didn't care
about the original data frame you just
created a subset that you further want
to work with but you want to get rid of
that warning and typically the
recommendation once you add a explicit
copy
but that means that you're actually
doing an unnecessary copy because the
subset was already a copy to start with
so
that brings me to a final like draw I
draw back about this current situation
is that you both the user
does unnecessary copying but also in
pandas internally we will do
um yeah there we do more copying than
what is needed
so how can we uh improve this can we do
better and so the the
um the experimental feature that is
included in uh in pandas 2.0
um is based on uh the single rule that
is described here so that any data frame
or series that was derived in some way
from another so through an indexing
operation as I showed in the example or
as a result of a method always behaves
as a copy
um if you rewrite this in terms of the
consequence of this is that if you want
to if you if you do change a data frame
if you mutate a data frame or a series
its values it only changes that object
itself and never any other so if you
want to modify a data frame you need to
directly modify that data frame and you
can't do that through some
other data frame
we think this
simplifies things and and has some yeah
has some advantages so to start a
simpler more consistent user experience
so if we go back to the first example
that I showed where my data frame I
create a subsets I modify the subsets
the question is now
a modifying subset but did the original
data frame the F change the answer is
very simple no because subset is a
different object I derived it from the
original data frame through an indexing
operation in this case so mutating
the data frame subset will never modify
indirectly another data frame so DF
wasn't changed and the answer is the
same regardless how I created subsets
whether I did that with the Boolean mask
as in this case or with the slides or
with the column selection or with the
method
Etc so that should simplify things
as a result of this we can actually also
get rid of the setting with copy warning
so
going back to the example that we showed
for the setting with copy running with
the current behavior of pandas the one
line like the one order of operations
works the order doesn't work
with the new Behavior
neither of those examples work
very simple
the reason so if you look at
um the the first one that currently does
work if you also rewrite this in two
lines we have a temporary object we
select a column and then we modify that
column but in this case also this
temporary like this series that we got
from the data frame is a new object
modifying that object will not modify
the original data frame so that means
that this change assignment essentially
never works
um as a result since it never works we
also don't need to warn about other
cases where you yeah
might have done something similarly so
we can in general like we can get rid of
the setting with copy warning of course
for upgrading there are so there were
cases where change assignment did work
and people are of course using that and
it won't work anymore in the future so
to uh to help with that transition and
also in general to one user in the
future
that they are doing something that will
never work there is a new warning and
potentially in the future we could make
this an error but the good thing about
this one is that it's always if you see
that warning you're doing something that
uh that doesn't work and so it's it's in
general you should never see it if you
avoid uh this this pattern
um
that was for the case where you wanted
to modify the data frame and so the the
other case where you didn't care and you
added this additional copy method just
to get rid of the burning the good news
here is that you no longer need this
additional copy to get rid of the
burning so this yeah this unnecessary
copy is no longer needed
it's no longer needed for you as a user
in your code but also internally in
pandas we can avoid a lot of
defensive copying improving the memory
usage and performance of of pandas
and so how does this work is that
because the single rule added the fvr at
the top it says that
it should behave behave as a copy it
doesn't say that it should be a copy
from the start only that it behaves as a
copy and so
under the hoods in pandas we can operate
for operations that allow it we can
avoid actually making a copy directly
when it's not needed and only later on
if you would modify something and to
ensure that we uh yeah we make this
guarantee of that it behaves as a copy
that's mutating one data frame doesn't
change the other only then we would make
a copy through what we call Copy and
write
to show you a small example of the
impact of this
very quick Benchmark a data Frame 2
million rows 30 columns it's on
different data types we do some yeah a
chain a method chain of renaming some
columns adding a new column dropping
some columns changing on types changing
the index
um
if I time that on my laptop with the
default behavior of pandas that takes
around 2.4 seconds
if you enable this new feature that goes
that goes down to 13 milliseconds
I know this is
[Applause]
I have to be honest it's a little bit
contrived example very explicitly took
all methods that don't really change
actual data but only like labels or
adding new columns so it are all methods
that currently each each step that we
show here currently takes a full copy of
your data with the new Behavior we never
copy the data here and so the the
difference in in what you see here in
performance is purely by avoiding all
those all those copies
a little bit more in detail how does
this exactly work so
um
with this copy on right so
assume that you have an operation that
actually makes a copy
for example the copy Methods at that
moment both the First Data frame and the
and the resulting data frame of the
methods they have their own data they
reference their own and own its own data
but if you do an operation that could be
a view for example a reset index most of
the columns can be shared between the
calling data frame and the resulting
data frame so in that case for the
columns that are shared they um
we keep track of the fact that they
share the same data
and only when you would then modify a
data frame df2 or df1 either of them we
can see that the data that they
reference are being shared by multiple
data frames and so to ensure that we
make this guarantee of it should behave
as it as it is a copy only at the moment
that we modify either of those data
frames at that moment we copy the data
so that each again has its own data and
we can modify df2 without modifying the
F1
but because in practice you much more
often do operations where we can avoid
this copy than actual mutating
operations uh yeah we can avoid a lot of
those copies
in practice
one last small thing if if you didn't
care about triggering this copy because
you don't care about keeping this
original data frame what you can always
do is reassign to the same variable for
example here the F1 reset index and I
reassigned it to df1
at that moment because the original
object so I'm still returning a new data
frame I just assign it to the same
variable these original objects goes out
of scope and in at the end the new df1
only has still is the only data frame
that reference its data and so we won't
trigger this
copy when modifying it
to conclude this part
how do I try this out it's included in
Partners 2.0 you can enable it through
that option
we very much want to encourage you to
try it out
based on your feedback
we hope and expect that it will become
the default in a future version of
pandas there are some links here with
some more details
um about that
[Applause]
so now we come to another experimental
feature data frames that are no longer
backed by numpy arrays they are they can
be backed by pi Arrow arrays now
the development for this has been
ongoing since 1.5
but it got a lot more stable if the 2.0
release
provides another mechanism to store data
in memory
um
I won't go into modif here and yours
gives a talk on Wednesday if you want to
learn more about arrow and how they help
improve the performance of data frame
libraries
as I said this is still experimental so
if you want to opt in you have to do
this explicitly there's no mechanism
right now where you can get priority
types everywhere there are two ways to
do this you can either use the arrow key
type Constructor which is an extension B
type in pandas
or you can declare it as a string with
the D type and Pi Arrow followed in
Brackets both of these notations are
completely equivalent except in one case
that we'll look later at
and you can choose whatever you prefer
if a data frame is backed by pi Arrow
arrays then we'll try to utilize Pi
Arrow compute functionality which is
depending on the use case significantly
faster than numpy or on par or a bit
slower we'll look into explicit examples
on the next couple of slides
the actual implementation on the panda
side is done by the extension array
interface this interface was initially
added in pandas 1.0 and was among others
used to represent pandasana level T
types
um
and this is used to dispatch to Paris
compute functions where they are
available
if we look at the small performance
example if you create a series with 5
million entries
integers between 1 and 100 so we get
plenty of duplicates
can we calculate the unique values then
numpy runs in around 10.6 milliseconds
Pi Arrow
gets this down to like 6.7 um so we get
a performance improvement from around 40
at 40 percent
that said if you do a lot of numerical
aggregations um then you're probably
better off using numpy because it's
highly optimized for this while parallel
um has other advantages
and also not every method of padness has
an equivalent compute function in pi
Arrow
so we have to work around this in some
areas which might cause performance
benefits um penalties not benefits
one of the bigger benefits of pyro is
that it has more built-in d-type support
than numpy
for example the numpy if you have an
integer array and you try to set missing
values into this array then you will
upcast to float this is not necessary in
any of the priority types all of them
have a missing value indicator
so you can keep your integer columns or
Boolean or whatever
one of the benefits that pandas utilizes
since version 1.3 is an efficient string
data type implementation
which isn't
very efficient if you want to operate on
the single strings
I already presents them contiguous in
memory which makes iterating over them
so much faster
a couple of model types that come
available through pyro are for example
bytes or decimal D types that are
especially helpful when you try to avoid
floating floating Point problems
an explicit null data type and nested
data structures that aren't very well
supported in pandas yet that said
there's still some work to be done to
support them properly we focused mostly
on the T types that have
a number equivalent up until now
the string D type is implemented in
pandas through the same notation as
we've seen before
but these are not equivalent yet the
pdrod type implementation the second one
over there is newer than the original
string pyro implementation
so they will probably become equivalent
in one of the next versions
what we've seen in our performance
benchmarks is that we get significantly
improved performance compared to numbers
object D type which is like logical
conclusion about when you take the
memory layout into account
and also they
take significantly less space and memory
I brought a small example for this um a
series with 1 million entries that has
completely random strings the length of
the strings is between 10 and 100 so
that we get a good variety
and we look at like two examples of the
pandas string accessor to these series
objects
if you look at the length function that
computes the length of every individual
object and we get a performance
improvement from around
from the factor factor 5.
um
the starts with function is even more
drastic this computes the first
character of all your strings which is
around 10 times faster
so we saw this for most methods that we
get a decent speed up with pi Arrow
another thing is the memory footprint in
this specific example the pi Arrow
string representation takes up around
half of the space of the numpy object
representation this might vary though
depending on your series if you have
lots of duplicates it could actually be
that the numpy object representation is
smaller in memory
so as I said earlier you have to opt
into priority types explicitly for now
to make this a bit easier and also to
improve performance we added a d-type
back-end keyword for most i o methods we
try to cover every one that we are aware
of that is commonly used
where you can request priority types
specifically one of the advantages of
doing this
within the i o method compared to
afterwards is that we can use Pi Arrow
inference key type inference while
reading the data
which avoids costly conversions from
your file to numpy and then to Pi Arrow
which might trigger a copy depending on
your data
a quick example with a short CSV file
object
we have three columns one integer with a
missing value one float column and one
string column
if you would read in with numpy first
then we would get like column A as a
float column back and then we would have
to copy it over to an integer column in
pi Arrow
column we would get object before and
then would have to copy it over by the D
type backend we can use the pi Arrow D
types
from the beginning
as I said earlier not all methods have
this yet if you encounter a method that
doesn't have a d type backend option
then you can convert use convert D types
afterwards to do the conversion in two
steps like reading first and then
converting to power
it's a bit slower but if you want to
work with the priority types it's not
too bad
a bit tied into our Arrow work is
something we have done for a couple of i
o methods
to know
the arrow framework offers a parsing
options and parsers for text files
they are multiple by default which means
that you get decent speed UPS depending
on the size of your file
when you're using it
we added this for read CSV and read Json
that are the two files that it's there's
other two file formats for which is is
it available right now
and also read pocket and read orc use
pyro natively that's the default engine
there
so a colleague from the panda score team
from us wrote a blog post about this and
he saw about 50 to 70 speed ups when
using the Aero engine for large CSV
files
this is mostly because of the booty
threading um the default the CSV in
which Json engines are custom
implementations from pandas itself
when you're using the arrow backend you
get zero copy because we get Arrow
objects back from these parsers and can
just store them in our extension arrays
which is really really really cheap but
you also see performance Improvement if
you use the these engines with the numpy
backend away enabled
you might trigger some copies but the
performance Improvement during reading
is still bigger than the penalty you get
from copying the data once
after we've seen all this potential
advantages of the priority types we
still have to give you a bit of a
warning this is similar to the
nanosecond resolution
um
the pandas API is huge and we are trying
to adopt it everywhere but we are not
there yet this will take us like at
least one more release
um so you might encounter some problems
because we have to cast to numpy simply
because the pi arrow implementations is
not available or not yet supported from
pandas
also in these areas our test coverage is
probably not that great because we
simply didn't get to it yet so you might
encounter potential bugs
two things I've seen on Reddit stack
Overflow and medium like a couple of
times since 2.0 came out that group I
emerge are slow
this is expected for now but will get
better in the future
also what we've seen we got like
probably 40 different issues about
payroll support in the LA over the last
two weeks a couple of them are because
of bugs in Arrow itself so they need to
be fixed by yours
um
before we can use them properly in
pandas
so a small medium-term roadmap what we
are planning on in over the next couple
of months
our first goal is to make sure that
arrow and numpy are basically equivalent
so if you switch between both of them um
you shouldn't encounter any problems
as I said this is still there's still
some work to be done and then the next
step we want to support the new d-types
properly like decimal by its nested data
structures or something I'm interested
in personally
and then as a second step we'll probably
provide a option that allows users to
opt into the rot type more easily
right now you have to request them
explicitly everywhere which might be a
bit bothersome
um in the long run
but yeah we encourage feedback and also
if you encounters something that's not
working as expected please file an issue
so that we can get to it and fix it
thank you
so for the last few minutes of our
presentation I want to say something
about Partners announcement proposals
acronym pdep or however you pronounce it
you will already have seen it appear a
few times in our presentation but so
it's a new process that was introduced
in the Panda's Community last year very
much similar as you have python the
python enhancement proposals peps or
numpyas naps and some other
projects have there have their version
so they are meant for larger changes or
changes that have a big impact on users
to write it down have a discussion about
it and be more transparent about those
upcoming changes
um
you can find more details about the
process in pwan
and you can also find all the PDFs on
the roadmap page of our website the
currently open ones are those four so
the ones that are being discussed I
don't have time to explain them all the
pdf7 is the one that we already went
into in detail before
and I briefly want to mention pdf8 about
in place so
in place is a keyboard that I think in
general the panelist developers are not
very fond about it's although it's used
a lot it's mostly synthetic synthetic
sugar for reassigning the results to the
the calling data frame and only very few
minutes actually work in place on the
the data itself and so the proposal but
to be explicit it's only a proposal it's
still being discussed is to actually
deprecate and remove most of the cases
where the In-Place keyword exists and
only keep it in certain places where the
actual operation can work in place on
the the data and not just the container
objects for example fill an a is an
example for that
all the other cases
for example reset index currently has a
re in place keyword
and how you would write this instead if
you are now using in place code is just
reassign it to the original variable and
that's
that's essentially what happens under
the hood but it just complicates pandas
having this keyboard in many places
where it's not that useful and that's
the link where you can find the full
explanation for that
to end I want to make it clear that
although Patrick and I
showed you some things about pandas it's
not because we talked here that we did
all that work it's only possible all
those new features and developments
because of yeah
the whole community of contributors I
put a one number there for the 2.0
release but there are of course even
more people actually contributing to
pandas
moreover you can also become part of
this community tomorrow is a good
opportunity opportunity to get started
there is a workshop in the afternoon to
start to learn how to start contributing
to Partners
um so that's uh the end of our
presentation you can find the slides in
that repo with all the information and
links and so we are happy to answer a
few questions
unfortunately I have sad news we don't
because we started let we don't have
time for questions but I hope the
speakers will be open to just answer
your question maybe in the hallway or
whenever you see them
so thank you very much again